sajid ali wades through the waters of
his flooded cotton field after days of
monsoon rains
he says his crop was worth around 7 500
and now he has to find another way to
earn an
income we've been working so hard on
this crop for months i'd taken out a
loan to plant it but now i have to go
and work on someone else's land because
we can't make ends meet
the damage is clear from above
with homes swept away and survivors
living in tents
around 60 families call this little town
in southern pakistan home raising crops
of cotton chilies and wheat
but now their livelihoods are in ruin
huge chunks of agricultural land has
been destroyed and hundreds of homes
have been swept away
our village thrives on cotton we pay for
our marriage functions for construction
of our houses from the income we get
from the crop it's costly to sow but the
income is also very high this time
though god wielded differently the rains
have devastated our crop almost entirely
we're sitting here at the mercy of god
with no help or rescue in sight
in flood-hit regions nationwide military
and rescue agencies are struggling to
reach those who've been stranded
with millions of residents at risk of
developing waterborne diseases
and for this region already dealing with
decades of drought the monsoon rains
should have been a welcome reprieve
not the cause of such destruction
chilling wolf al jazeera